when you get a call oh do you want to
join the Indie franchise is that a very
quick yes
yeah I mean he could have said do you
want to play a cat yeah I'll play a cat
Indiana Jones sure when he hung up his
head it was quite emotional for all of
us we were all there for the last take
the last season right
and uh so we applauded and humble last
year she's just you just want to leave
he doesn't want to get out of there but
it was a big part of him that wanted to
stay there for a thousand years as well
so that it was quite beautiful
so enduring about Indie generation after
generation if I knew that I'll be a
billionaire It's a combination obviously
of Lucas Spielberg and a lot of it is
Harrison right I mean did you play a
part yeah play the character yeah but
could be able to add that charm I don't
think anyone else can do it